ouais sanofi toujours pas de vaccin
contre locaux vides mais un dividende en
hausse
une annonce du géant pharmaceutique de
verser plus de 4 milliards d'euros à ses
actionnaires alors et qu'ils suppriment
des emplois notamment dans la recherche
suscite bien évidemment la polémique
une générosité que le groupe justifie
par de bons résultats et par un contexte
très concurrentiel qui l'obligent à
rester attractif mais cette hausse de
dividende en pleine crise sanitaire est
elle aussi scandaleuse qu'elle n'y
paraissait l'objet de l'élite aux échos
ce soir bonsoir jacques sapir merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur arte
france soir c'est fini alors jacky y at
il réellement une affaire sanofi alors
oui on peut le penser à première vue
effectivement sanofi a des gros
problèmes avec la mise au point de son
vaccin sanofi vient de supprimer 1700
postes dont 400 dans la recherche et
dans le même temps sanofi augmente son
dividende donc on peut penser qu'
effectivement un scandale maintenant et
il faut quand même voir que cette
augmentation de dividende
elle n'est pas très importante on était
à 3 euros 15 en 2019 on sera trois euros
20 en 2020
il faut aussi savoir que cette
augmentation de dividende
elle correspond à une augmentation des
profits mais dû à la revente d'une
société qui appartenait à sanofi la
société régénérant celle qui avait fait
le traitement à base d'anticorps qui a
été donnée à donald trump
donc on peut se poser quand même la
question suivante qui est de savoir est
ce qu'il n'ya pas un vrai scandale mais
ce scandale est ce que ça ne serait pas
beaucoup plus dans la stratégie qu'a
suivi sanofi depuis ces dernières années
ainsi jeunes vous nous dites que la
hausse du dividende est faible dans
quelle mesure alors si vous voulez comme
je vous le dis les dividendes ils sont
passés 2,3 euros 15 en 2010 9 à 3 euros
vin c'est pas énorme
par contre maintenant si on regarde
l'évolution des dividendes depuis 2000
quand on voit qu'ils ont beaucoup monté
de 2004 à 2007 2009 ils ont augmenté de
plus de 50% et qu'ils recommencent à
augmenter de manière assez sensible
depuis 2016 2017
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que
sanofi est une société qui fait gagner
de l'argent à ses actionnaires c'est
très bien mais quand elle fait gagner de
l'argent à ce niveau là et dans ces
proportions là eh bien ça veut dire que
sanofi est levée passez moi l'expression
cracher du cash
autrement dit elle sert les coûts
partout où c'est possible
elle ne développe que les activités qui
sont le plus profitable
un autre élément à prendre aussi en
compte c'est la valeur de l'action le
cours de l'action la capitalisation
or là aussi on voit qu'il ya une forte
augmentation
une augmentation de plus de 40 % de 2004
à 2020 et même si on prend simplement
l'augmentation jusqu'à fin 2019
c'est pratiquement 50% donc là aussi il
y a un très gros problème et on peut
penser que c'est l'ensemble du modèle de
sanofi qui est aujourd'hui en cause
alors jacques à cette hausse du
dividende n'est pas un problème en
substance c'est pas exactement ce que
j'ai dit saoulé quand il ya des
dividendes
c'est qu'il ya des profits alors il
faudrait voir à quoi correspondent les
profits pour 2020 on sait que pour 2018
et 2019
les chiffres qui s'affiche sur l'écran
sont ceux des comptes de sanofi bas on
voit très bien quel a été le chiffre
d'affaires de cette entreprise ou votre
c'est un chiffre d'affaires qui tourne
autour de 71 % pour les médicaments
d'entre 15 et 16% pour ce qui est des
vaccins et 13% à peu près pour ce qui
est des produits de santé autrement dit
des choses qui relèvent plutôt de la
parapharmacie
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 2020
mais en 2020 la société a comme je les
dis revendu une filiale régénérant qui
est une filiale qui a réalisé un très
beau coup parce que c'est elle qui a mis
au point justement ce traitement contre
le co lead qui a été acheté en
particulier par l'allemagne ce
traitement à base d'anticorps
alors on peut se poser la question si
vous voulez on voit dire que le profit
de 2020 n'est pas durable cette histoire
de vendre une société sanofi ne pourra
pas le recommencer
toutes les années c'est un fusil à un
coup donc qu'est-ce qu'on fait des
profits est ce qu'on doit nécessairement
les distribuer aux actionnaires ou
justement parce que sanofi rencontrent
des problèmes industriels dans la mise
au point de son vaccin des problèmes
dont on espère qu'ils seront résolus
mais est ce qu'il ne faudrait pas plutôt
mettre de l'argent pour la recherche ou
provisionné d'une certaine manière se
constituer un matelas pour des années
plus difficiles
donc là il ya déjà un premier problème
au niveau de la stratégie de sanofi
alors jack qui sont ses actionnaires
alors c'est extrêmement intéressant
en fait si on regarde fonctionnellement
on voit que pratiquement 80 % de
l'actionnariat de sanofi dépend de ce
qu'on appelle des investisseurs
institutionnels que ces investisseurs
institutionnels soit étranger ils
représentent environ 60% ou qu'ils
soient français ils représentent environ
16% te fais l'actionnariat après c'est
essentiellement une grande entreprise
française même si elle est gérée par un
américain l'oréal et puis il y à des
particuliers on voit d'ailleurs que les
salariés ne représente que 1 27%
sur ce total ça c'est je dirais une
analyse fonctionnelle
après si on regarde par pays c'est aussi
très intéressant on dit beaucoup que
sanofi est une entreprise française
mais enfin les actionnaires français ne
représente que 36% du capital le reste
de l'europe représente environ 27 % les
etats-unis 35% et là dedans il y a en
particulier le fonds blackrock
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que sanofi c'est une société qui
s'est très largement financiarisé et qui
s'est globalisée depuis grosso modo le
début des années 2000 cette société
n'est absolument pas le champion
français que l'on nous décrit elle n'a
plus grand-chose de française en réalité
alors messi sanofi va effectivement
supprimer un dea en point jacques ne
va-t-il pas en créer d'autres avec la
sous traitance pour le vaccin de pfizer
com
d'ailleurs proposé où effectivement il y
à cet accord de sous traitance qui a été
passé avec pfizer maintenant ses effets
sur l'emploi sanofi ou sur la capacité
technologique de sanofi seront
extrêmement limité parce qu'il faut
quand même le dire c'est un accord avec
pfizer qui portent uniquement sur le
flaconnage autrement dit sur l'emballage
du vaccin sanofi va recevoir en fait le
produit
et puis va se contenter de le mettre
dans des petites bouteilles dans ces
petits flacons qui contiennent
maintenant si dose dit on bon c'est pas
quand même extrêmement glorieux
techniquement et pourquoi alors pourquoi
ben voilà c'est juste un problème c'est
uniquement de la sous traitance et de la
sous-traitance qui est très très très
peu intéressante
il y avait pourtant une autre voie qui
était possible quand sanofi a commencé à
comprendre que la mise au point de son
vaccin durer plus longtemps que ce qui
était prévu
et ça ça date en fait de la fin de
l'année et bien
sanofi aurait peu cherché à rentrer en
contact avec par exemple des autres
producteurs de vaccins pour obtenir des
licences
prenons le cas de scouts nick v de
l'institut gamaleya le gouvernement
français est informé en réalité de la
capacité et des effets de spoutnik v
depuis grosso modo le mois de décembre
c'est là où il ya une mission d' enquête
qui a été envoyé par le gouvernement
français à l'institut gamaleya
astrazeneca a immédiatement décidé de
rentrer dans un accord avec l'institut
gamaleya pourquoi est-ce que sanofi ne
l'a pas fait pourquoi est-ce que sanofi
n'a pas cherché justement à obtenir
cette licence
car même si la production de vaccins ne
pourraient commencer que fin juin ou en
juillet en supposant que le vaccin soit
homologué à la
du mois de février ou au début du mois
de mars malgré tout cela apporterait une
contribution extrêmement importante
au programme vaccinal français parce
qu'il faudra pas il faut rappeler que
scout nigré c'est un vaccin qui est
quasiment aussi efficace que pfizer et
c'est un vaccin qui est beaucoup plus
simple d'emploi qui ne demandent pas du
tout les mêmes précautions au niveau de
la chaîne de transport et de la chaîne
logistique
par ailleurs une cession de licences
c'est quand même autrement plus
intéressant que de faire du flaconnage
alors jacques finalement les dividendes
de sanofi en envers notre première
question scandale ou non eh bien je
dirais que healy à certains scandales
avec sanofi mais qu'il n'est pas
nécessairement là où on le croit il
n'est pas nécessairement sur la question
des dividendes
oui effectivement sanofi va distribuer
des dividendes mais ce n'est pas une
augmentation qui est si importante que
cela le véritable scandale
c'est plutôt l'évolution générale de
cette société depuis maintenant au moins
une quinzaine d'années une société qui
sait financiarisé qui s'est globalisée
et qui est maintenant dans une logique
du profit immédiat du profit à très
court terme ce qui l'a amené à préférer
rentrer dans une logique de sous
traitance de flaconnage pour un grand
groupe américain pfizer
plutôt que de tenter de décrocher la
licence pour un vis un véritable vaccin
avec l'institut gamaleya en russie merci
jacques en tout cas pour ce point de vue
plutôt inédit merci
à vous